bonjour sébastien jumel merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france alors 35 vaccinodromes en
cours d'installation on l'a vu en france
avec la mise à contribution de l'armée
le gouvernement at il bien fait de
changer d'avis selon vous il était temps
voilà plusieurs semaines géré - ou des
territoires les maires se mobilisent la
communauté mondiale se font vives la
communauté hospitalière se mobilisent
pour dire qu'il faut accélérer le schéma
vaccinal à chez moi à diable nous avons
mis en place des unités mobiles de
vaccination un centre de vaccination
j'ai mobilisé plus de trente médecins y
compris des retraités pour faire la
démonstration qu'on était opérationnel
mais il nous manquait des doses d'être
heureux et j'ai demandé mon directeur de
la rs de faire ça chez nous en
seine-maritime aux un département qui
vient d'être confiné nous puissions
enfin accélérer la vaccination et pas
seulement dans les métropoles mais aussi
dans les villes moyennes dans les
territoires qui souvent se sont oubliés
par la république alors vous l'avez dire
pour remplir ces vaccinodromes il faut
il faut ces fameuses doses sur lesquels
mise le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand elles sont prévues dit il pour
vous en ce moment là les les doses dans
votre département sont toujours en
rupture de stock ou pas et pour
l'instant le rythme n'est pas
satisfaisant dans un territoire comme le
mien diable nous avions jusqu'à présent
170 par jour en bassin de vie est
d'environ cent mille habitants au nord
de mon département a eu le tréport dans
une région très ouvrière on était tombé
à 32 doses par jour alors qu'il nous en
faut évidemment beaucoup plus si l'on
veut vacciner d'abord les plus fragiles
mais aussi ensuite tous ceux qui le
souhaitent
moi je ne m'habitue pas avoir la vie
confinée je m'habitue pas avoir la
culture enfermé je ne m'habitue pas
avoir nos enfants privés d'activités
sportives et d'aller à l'école
d'ailleurs à mi temps désormais pour les
lycéens est la seule manière de se
sortir de cela c'est de la frime
se rattrape son retard en matière de
vaccination cette solution mais pour
l'instant il n'ya pas les vaccins alors
on a un taux d'incidence qui est de 550
pour ligne de france aujourd'hui avec un
confinement qui n'en est pas vraiment un
est ce que c'est la bonne méthode selon
vous aujourd'hui pour réduire les
tensions hospitalières
non c'est une vision technocratique
derrière moi j'ai appris que mon
département étaient confinés alors que
je suis député et les maires du
département de la même manière en
écoutant la télé en étant suspendu aux
lèvres du premier ministre parce que le
président décide de tout et de rien tout
seul la solution c'est de vacciner et la
solution c'est de réarmer l'eau c'est à
dire de donner les moyens à l'hôpital
d'absorber les pics de fréquentation
notamment en écoutant ceux qui en
réanimation des propositions concrètes à
faire pour réarmer des services de
réanimation sur bâton de l'hôpital le
chef de l'état qui redoutent avant tout
le ras-le-bol des français face à de
nouvelles mesures de restriction
on l'a vu à marseille on va en parler
voyez ce qu'on se rend lundi l'un de ses
ministres en coulisses
sa crainte c'est que le pays se
transforme en cocotte minute que ça pète
de partout souligna ministre ils voient
bien les sondages sur le moral des
français
la détresse des restaurateurs des
cinémas sans parler de la jeunesse et vu
ce qui s'est passé à à marseille est-ce
que selon vous cette crainte est fondée
mais oui parce que 20 lits serait temps
que le gouvernement s'aperçoivent que la
france est en détresse
aucune réponse satisfaisante concrètes
pour contrer des exclamations la
désespérance de de la jeunesse et puis
il ya un besoin
marseille est l'illustration de ça alors
pour les choses ont géré n'importe
comment voilà ce que ça produit de gens
qui ont envie notamment de jeunes qui
ont envie que la vie reprenne le dessus
et on ne peut pas leur en vouloir
je crois qu'il ya là français ont fait
montre de beaucoup de discipline de
beaucoup d'altruisme des locaux
de sérieux et il était prêt à consentir
cela à condition que ça s'appuie sur une
capacité de l'état à prendre soin de la
population force est de constater que un
an après aucun enseignement n'a été tiré
et on aboutit aux débordements comme
celui que vous montrez sur vos images
qui ne évidemment qu'ils ne me satisfont
pas mais que j'explique par le besoin
que la vie reprenne le dessus alors le
gouvernement qui en fait aussi une
question politique gérald darmanin qui a
annoncé dès des poursuites après ce
carnaval sauvage à mars à y regarder il
y a eu des interpellations
dès demain d'ailleurs des comparutions
immédiates et j'ai demandé à madame la
préfète de police des bouches du rhône
de prendre toutes les dispositions pour
identifier les organisateurs est de
permettre à l'autorité judiciaire de les
poursuivre plusieurs membres de la
république en marche on parce qu'avec ce
carnaval est infiltré par des éléments
de l'ultra gauche
quel est votre sentiment sur cette
politisation en tout cas l'événement
je ne suis pas marseillais je ne sais
pas comment ce mouvement spontané est né
ce que je constate c'est que la
démocratie du bâton ça ne marche pas et
qu'on ferait mieux de mobiliser l'état
pourtant besoin des gens pour vacciner
pour réarmer l'hôpital pour entendre la
complainte des soignants pour faire en
sorte que on écoute les élus on applique
des confinement dans mon département y
compris lors philippe l'ancien premier
ministre l'a dit ou confine ensemble du
département alors que les chiffres
boucle de circulation du virus sont sans
commune mesure entre la métropole
rouennaise et puis le havre et dieppe et
de grandir le virus circule beaucoup
moins mon fils incompréhension avec les
commerçants savez moi dans ma vie j'ai
une commerçante qui s'est fait embarquer
par la police dimanche
parce qu'elle sortait des habits dans la
rue pour les photographier afin de
préparer le click and collect ans les
bras comment ces violents alors que les
collections de printemps sont arrivés
alors que les stocks ont été
reconstitués
les commerçants aprem du jour au
lendemain qu'ils vont à nouveau 2
voir fermer les rideaux moi je comprends
l'exaspération la colère le ras-le-bol
et je serai ton coup leur inquiétude est
également dans les écoles le virus est
très actif dans les écoles ou non le
taux de contamination est bien supérieur
à la moyenne nationale le ministre de la
santé le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer rla
lui-même admis écoutez la réaction des
syndicat scolaire nous solidaires
étudiante et ep de lyon et le collectif
pamplemousse nous interrogeons sur la
présence de la licra au sein de cette
programmation et plus globalement de son
partenariat avec sciences po lyon en
raison des nombreuses ambiguïtés la
concernant notamment vis-à-vis de son
rapport à l'islamophobie ainsi qu'à la
laïcité c'est pas le bon c'est pas la
bonne réaction évidemment les syndicats
s'inquiètent en tout cas de cette montée
du virus dans les écoles les écoles qui
sont bien des foyers de contamination
alors que jean michel blanc karl a
toujours nié pour vous est-ce que
c'était un mensonge assumer pour garder
les écoles ouvertes
vichy neil moi j'ai trois enfants
l'étudiant lycéens et ils collégienne et
bien quel point les enfants qui portent
en eux aussi un faux d'autres de
discipline sont conduits à faire
circuler le virus parce qu'ils déjeunent
ensemble à la grande chine qu'ils se
retrouvent dans la cour d'école et non
pas leur contre chez taïfu d'ailleurs
les déculpabiliser là dessus moi je
partage l'idée qu'il fallait et qu'il
faut laisser les écoles ouvertes
par contre je m'étonne on ne renforce
pas plus des tests dans les écoles et je
m'étonne que on anticipe à j'allais dire
va nécessiter un moment donné de
vacciner notamment les plus jeunes pour
protéger non seulement nos aînés non
seulement les plus fragiles mais
l'ensemble de la population
on va venir c'est sur ces réactions ddd
syndicat étudiant à sciences po qui
décidément fait beaucoup parler de lui
ces dernières semaines dernière
politique en date a strasbourg les
règles de désignation du nom de la
promotion ont été modifié à la dernière
minute parce que c'est le nom de samuel
pâtit qui a remporté l'adhésion générale
la direction a donc préféré jouer la
parité en
signant une femme regardez cette
décision a automatiquement créé la
colère au sein de la promotion et nombre
d'étudiants se sont interrogés sur la
véritable raison de cette démarche
l'idéologie et les militants d'extrême
gauche font la loi et n'hésitent plus à
fouler du pied la mémoire des martyrs de
la liberté
que pensez vous de ce tour de
passe-passe vous en aviez connaissance
non pas du tout je m'étonne de de tant
de polémiques
il n'est pas illégitime évidemment peu
on en chie diable lorsque nous ne
s'appelle pas ti symbole d'une certaine
manière des enseignants dévoués aux
valeurs de la république mais je pense
que gagnerait à ce que la ministre à ce
que le gouvernement arrête de
stigmatiser les syndicates jeunesse est
au contraire considèrent que la vitalité
démocratique des jeunes des étudiants
est aussi la vitalité de la démocratie
de demain
arrêtons de montrer du doigt des jeunes
regardons dans la paille du gouvernement
ses propres turpitudes et faisons en
sorte d'être au rendez vous de
l'histoire pour prendre soin de la
population moi je je je n'en peux plus
j'ai lu une étude de mediapart ou me dis
que la polémique créée par la ministre
vidal était une polémique pour faire en
sorte d'exister dans la crise alors
qu'elle avait été incapable d'écouter la
détresse étudiante j'ai le sentiment que
cette version de son de la bonne merci
beaucoup on terminera donc sur ces mots
merci sébastien jumel d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct à nos questions sur rt
france